foreign
[Music]
if you've ever wondered what it might
take to upset a microscopist just ask
James our master of microscopes his
feelings about tardigrade legs
part of grade legs those chunky Wiggly
limbs that move their owner through
needles of moss and Fields of debris
what could possibly be in question when
it comes to tardigrade Lakes why would
such a seemingly mundane detail of the
invisible world around us become a
repeated point of contention in Journey
to the microcosmos meetings the problem
lies in the macroscopic world
specifically in the Myriad of stuffed
tardigrade toys available for purchase
and the fact that many of them seem to
have had a fact checking problem take a
moment right now to count the number of
legs you see on this tardigrade
you should have hopefully counted four
pairs making for a grand total of eight
squirmy limbs on our little water bear
friend but unfortunately many tardigrade
toy manufacturers seem to have stopped a
little short in their counting while
there are eight legged tardigrades for
sale you'll also find plenty of spurious
ones that only have six legs so to this
day the question of whether we should
produce our own Journey to the micro
Cosmos tardigrade merchandise comes up
including our t-shirts James is the
first to remind us that it would be an
opportunity to correct the record in
some small way
now if you have spent your life thinking
of tardigrades as six-legged creatures
don't worry we have made the same
mistake and have had to correct previous
videos where we described them as having
six legs and we're not quite sure what
it is about these creatures that
confuses the Watchers in this way but we
are all in good company because the
question of just how to count tardigrade
legs has been around since their
discovery and it's not the only quality
of tardigrades that has inspired
disagreement this creature has been
confounding us for centuries and while
sometimes the scientific sticks have
been pretty low at other times they have
been much higher the tardigrade was
first described by Johann August Ephraim
godza a preacher who in his 40s had only
just begun his microscopy hobby but the
beauty of the microcosmos is that it can
reveal itself to anyone willing to look
regardless of experience and in 1773
gertza would put the experience of
watching a tardigrade into words for the
first time
he said strange is this little creature
because the whole organization of his
body is extraordinary and strange and
because his external appearance at the
first sight as the closest similarity to
a little bear
kurza called his strange creature Klein
vaser bars or little water bear a name
that has stuck as a nickname for the
tardigrade and about this little water
bear which he also at times called a
worm he said the most remarkable feature
of this little worm are the eight short
feet of which each is armed with three
crooked and very sharp claws
but while gertz's publication was the
first to describe a tardigrade it would
not be the only one for long within a
few years three other scientists would
document their observations and
inferences on the unusual creatures
found swimming around in duckweeds and
rain gutters those scientists were
Johann Conrad icorn bonaventura courti
and Lazarus palanzani
these papers were likely written
independently of one another and some of
the features they described did not line
up particularly the legs icorn drew a
figure with 10 legs though we have no
idea where he got 10 from meanwhile
spalanzani described a creature with six
legs though that seemed to be due to the
fact that he considered the last pair of
tardigrade legs to not be legs at all
but instead a pair of hooked filaments
of course a few mistakes here and there
do not prevent one from making important
contributions to our Collective
knowledge and one of the most lasting
contributions of spalenzani was the fact
that he called these creatures
which translates to sluggard or slow
Walker of course that name since shifted
into what we now call tardigrade
quite clear to us how the consensus that
tardigrades have eight legs was settled
in 1785 a posthumous publication written
by the Danish naturalist Otto Friedrich
Mueller established the correct number
as eight and a translator of
spalanzani's work a man named John
Graham daliel wrote in the footnotes of
his translation about a species he'd
found himself and named tardigratus
octap Dallas better known as the
tardigrade with eight legs so at some
point toy manufacturers aside there was
an agreement that tardigrades have eight
legs not six not ten eight it appears to
have been maybe unsurprisingly a
relatively low stakes and low-key
argument in the world of tardigridology
after all if you can just look at them
and be like see count there's eight then
it's fairly easy to settle the argument
but not all arguments have been this way
in the middle of the 19th century a
156-page report was written by Pierre
Paul broca a French physicist best known
for his research on the brain so why was
broca writing about an eight-legged slow
walking microscopic creature well he was
there to settle an argument an old one
that gets to the core of tardigrades and
their remarkable capacity to survive
today we know that water bears and many
other microscopic animals are able to
survive extreme conditions of heat or
dryness by draining themselves of water
defecating into a husk that essentially
puts their life on pause until
conditions become tolerable again
we know this process today as
anhydrobiosis and it was first described
in tardigrades by bonaventura courti who
had observed rotifers and other
creatures going through it as well but
as more scientists documented the
anhydrobiosis of tardigrades more
questions began to form around just what
anhydrobiosis was was it death a state
of pause
to answer that tardigridologists had to
agree on something even more fundamental
could tardigrades and their fellow dried
out creatures live past anhydrobiosis
after all logic and experience suggest
that voiding oneself entirely of
moisture is not a sound survival
strategy on the one hand there were
experiments carried out by spalanzani
and others that seemed to demonstrate
the conditions necessary to make
anhydrobiosis a state that tardigrades
could resuscitate themselves from but
others did not believe this kind of
Resurrection was possible and in their
quest to explain what others were seeing
some very creative alternative
explanations popped up for example the
eminent naturalist Christian Gottfried
aarenberg believed that people were
actually seeing the descendants of the
dried out animal emerging from the husk
of their great great grandparent and in
1859 China this led to the involvement
of the society day biology in Paris a
commission that was called to settle the
debate as presented by two French
scientists one side was Felix archimede
Boucher who believed that tardigrades
could not be revived from anhydrobiosis
on the other side there was Louis
Michelle Francois doyer who had
documented his tardigrade Resurrection
experiments in his dissertation titled
Memoir sule tardigrad I'm sure you're
all so happy to hear my French
pronunciation both side documented their
experiments and the commission performed
control experiments resulting eventually
in the report written by Paul broca that
stated that doyer was correct
tardigrades that go through
anhydrobiosis can in fact be brought
back to life from that state of course
settling this debate only opened the
door for more for questions that we are
still trying to answer about the
mechanisms that allowed tardigrapes to
survive anhydrobiosis and the limits to
their resilience but that is the joy of
science the way that disagreements
compel us to strengthen our own
arguments to seek out the tools and
experiments that will help us better
understand the world around us
and perhaps on that note we should end
with something that we hope we can all
agree on as fellow hitchhikers through
the microcosmos it's a note from gertz's
1773 paper where he first described the
little water bears that he had found
surely there is no greater pleasure than
to see the polyps the rotifers and the
other beasts of prey under the
magnifying glass seizing and swallowing
their prey this can be achieved without
traveling long distances without risking
one's life and without big costs a Glass
Lens shows us a new world and I know
from experience that you will be full of
Amazement when seeing that for the first
time
foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us we love diving into
history here on Journey to the
microcosmos but it's important to
remember that history is not just the
same thing as the past the past is
everything that has ever happened
history is the curated story of all of
the important events but who gets to
choose what's important and what
influences that decision well study hall
U.S history to 1865 seeks to explore
these questions as they cover American
history from the earliest indigenous
groups to the Civil War so if you're
sitting there craving a bit more history
today you can head on over to
youtube.com study hall or click on the
link in the description to watch study
hall U.S history to 1865.
the people on the screen right now they
are our patrons on patreon and we are so
grateful that they give us the
opportunity to dive deep and learn about
not just what we know now but how we
came to know it that for me is the most
interesting and most special thing about
science which is not a body of
information that just appeared somewhere
it is all stuff that human beings
figured out so thank you so much to all
the people on the screen right now for
helping us tell these stories if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign
[Music]